今日はこちら stick up です今日は最後の音じゃなくて明日は最後にいい
ですね日本の
今回の外日の7日日ですかああの福岡のポリゴッド会議に参加して
そしてまあ大阪と東京でいろんなその
まあ
言葉の勉強に関してですね有休
ユーチューバーとかいろいろしその他たちに会いました
非常に面白いその学校もね
東京でまぁ
うんして書庫がですね家族というかたくさんも呼んでくださいと家族というそういう
あの子して向けね
英語を教えている学校が訪ねましたそれの効果はあるか2位までの在来のよ教え方
文法とか頭行くとかそういうようなものに比べて効果的で
で今日は大阪でマルゼン
本屋さん
当時訪ねましてね
音ばその勉強の社9社がかなり大きいですよね
しかしまぁ多分2割3割は公益とか
英検とかあるいはまあ中国とか韓国語とかね
それぞれの言葉の被験をどうやって合格するかという本がもう
極めて多いそれは本当には yahoo
仕方ないと思いますそれよりもたくさん読んでたくさん聞いてねっ
それが
もっと効果的ですね
でそれぞれの本が3000円2000円3000円も
こっちするわけですよねー
ただにタイムになりますよだからまあこれからどういう風にリンクがね
日本のその pot ばを英語だけじゃなくて言葉を勉強する人たちに対してどういう
ようなは逆 y を果たせるかくるがこれからの私の楽しみのまあ一つの手
はですまあまあ
[音楽]
ん
んっ
[音楽]
me
ni
[音楽]
uh